Ninety-nine percent of the world is convinced they can't do great things,...
...so they shoot for the middle.
They shoot for realistic goals,...
...which means that realistic goals are the most competitive place to be.
Therefore, unrealistic goals are less competitive because no one's going for them.
So, don't overestimate the competition and underestimate yourself.
You're probably better than you think.
There's this great quote from "Into the Wild", the film.
It's, "Happiness is only real when it's shared."
And we really believe that,...
...and when I think back about the adventures in the past nine years...
...and the things that we've done, it's the things that we've done for other people...
...that I know will stick with me until I die.
So, the thing I want to leave you guys with is,...
...what do you want to do before you die?
Thank you.